las consecuencias de la guerra están
lejos de ser un recuerdo en Colombia
según lo reveló el comité Internacional
de la Cruz Roja el país latinoamericano
conoció la multiplicación y el
fortalecimiento de los grupos armados en
2022 y también sus efectos uno de los
datos más alarmantes fueron las 515
víctimas de artefactos explosivos la
mayor cifra en seis años 278 de estas
fueron civiles y 43 menores de edad el
balance en términos de desplazamiento
tampoco es alentador
123.000 personas tuvieron que dejar sus
territorios de manera individual 10% más
con respecto a 2021 las cifras explican
en gran parte por la presencia de siete
conflictos con diferentes actores en
2022 uno más que en el año anterior y
que afectan a ciertas regiones del país
con mayor ferocidad tal como expuso a
France 24 Lorenzo caráfi jefe de la
delegación de la Cruz Roja en Colombia
efectivamente las zonas de frontera con
Venezuela el occidente del país sur del
país siguen las más afectadas son las
zonas donde se da la lucha para control
territorial entre los actores armados el
control social de los actores armados y
la población civil está afectada no solo
por las consecuencias directas de los
enfrentamientos pero se encuentra en el
medio de la lucha para el control
territorial la Cruz Roja reconoció las
iniciativas del gobierno de Gustavo
Petro el primero de izquierda en el país
que ha buscado hacer efectiva su
política de paz Total que pretende
acabar con el conflicto a pesar de los
avances en los diálogos con el ejército
de liberación nacional la guerrilla más
longeva de Colombia el gobierno hizo
truncada su negociación con el clan del
Golfo uno de los grupos narcotraficantes
más importantes del país